What is the best subject field to choose
as a beginner in the field of seeking
Islamic knowledge in the Islamic
University of Medadina? Because I have
been granted a chance to study there. I
mean what should I take? Sharia, aka
Quran, Hadith, Arabic,
Jakaman, Yashik. It is because all of my
family members are non-Muslims and I am
the only one who accepted Islam and I am
the only one who studying Islam here in
our place. Kindly give me some guidance.
I am the youngest in our siblings 19
years old.
Chris Sigara from Philippine, mashallah,
he accepted Islam and he's been granted
admission in the Islamic University of
Medadina which is one of the best
Islamic universities for studying Islam
in the world and all his family members
are non-Muslims. He's asking what should
he take? Should he take Sharia or Hadith
or
etc. Studying in Medadina, taking
bachelors in any of the Islamic studies
is good mashallah. But if given the
choice I personally advise that if you
want to be
adai whichever field you take no problem
but the best amongst all available I
advise to take bachelor's in Sharia
first but naturally you have to do two
years of mahad that's learning Arabic
language and after you finish your mahad
in Arabic which is compulsory for all
you're 19 years old you'll have to learn
Arabic as a language for two years and
after you finish the Arabic course then
I would request you that you should join
Sharia. There is even taps of the Quran
there is hadith then there
is
also but I personally prefer Sharia
because Sharia
includes hadith as well as and
especially for knowing the reasons of
why the rulings are there in Islam and
the fatwas and the fake Sharia is my
first choice. So normally I prefer
advising people Sharia and then after
that you can either take or had there's
no problem and the last would be but the
first choice if you get admission
preferably I would advise you to take
Sharia because that includes studying
the of the Quran includes studying
hadith and also includes fick and when
you learn fick you have the knowledge of
how to give arguments and what are the
reasons and skills which will help you
more helpful for dawa. You can do dawa
even with even with hadith etc. Sharia
would be the first option. Inshallah I
pray to Allah subhanaa tala that may he
grant you knowledge and make you a good
d so that you can convey the message to
your family members to your friends and
your other non-Muslim colleagues and may
Allah subhananaa tala give you the fid
and accept your efforts in his